Allison Williams unrecognizable in a  lure that was crazy the brunette beauty  switches things up going platinum for  the beauty mags march issue the cover  proudly proclaims there's a new blonde  in town and yes it's real Allison shared  this selfie after the cover reveal quote  still getting used to it but I dig it  Allison says the change is to help her  say goodbye to her girls character Marni  Jameson always be tricked you think I'm  gonna stop being your friend now after  putting up with all this bull the HBO  hits final season premieres sunday since  just been waves and waves and waves of  emotion like it's not even consolidated  I thought like when I rap that was maybe  the heaviest moment no it just keeps  going it was emotional getting ready  tonight to knowing the last time  [Music]